Sherman, je ne savais pas si tu voudrais
revoir quelqu'un comme moi, cela fait
sept ans, femme et enfants,
tout comme nous avions l'habitude de parler de rêve
de savoir que tu as toute cette vie
maintenant comme si rien ne s'était jamais passé, c'est que
ce que tu  veux m'installer je ne sais pas
peut-être que si je trouvais une fille qui
m'aurait la vie civile tout le monde est si suffisant et
lacé qu'ils disent que l'univers est
infini bien s'il est infini
où n'y a-t-il pas de place pour moi il
s'installe  quand il devrait
chercher une issue, c'était devant et je veux dire que
tu as oublié qui tu es c'est ce qui ne
va pas hommes femmes enfants ils sont tous
violents essaient d'entraîner un homme guéri
dans ta maladie ne va pas
te guérir  oh c'est ce que je fais je
ne veux pas être dans notre maison je ne le
veux pas dans notre ville
toi